hi uh i'm andrew and
i'm really indecisive
normally that's okay since it just
affects
me and my personal development and my
ability to watch movies
but unfortunately i'm also a writer and
the thing about writing is that you're
always making decisions
every word you choose every line break
you insert every little bit of
punctuation
it's just countless decisions and
through all of these decisions there's a
lot of pressure
to make the right one
every time you pick a word it's it's
there's all of these wrong choices to
make and there's one right choice to
make and you're expected to find the
right
choice and i don't necessarily believe
that right choice exists
and it to be honest makes me
uncomfortable having to choose
a word because i i feel guilty
leaving out all the other words because
they were perfectly fine they didn't do
anything wrong they deserve to have
their
time of day so um i want to
find a way to not exclude them
so i made a thing this thing is called
bml or the blur markup language
it's a programming language for writing
text
that changes uh
rather than writing exactly what you
want people to read
you express the possibilities and these
are then chosen for you
on demand so here we have um
a basic summary of what the language is
and a bunch of different ways to write
it out like we can spell bml lowercase
as i prefer or
uppercase or you can fully spell out the
acronym
and then we can describe it as maybe
it's lightweight or hacky
all these different things that can
happen and you can see five different
ways that it's been realized below
and hopefully you can kind of see that
all the details change and the number of
permutations that could occur here is
really quite large um
but at the same time the shape of it the
meaning behind the text
somehow stays the same so let's talk
about the language a little bit
inline choices we have these um and
you've already seen these so
this is just listing a bunch of
different things that can happen and we
can assign different weights to them so
in this case we're doing a b and c
a is going to happen fifty percent of
the time b is going to happen thirty
percent of the time
and then c is going to take up whatever
remaining probability we have
and below in all these examples you kind
of see
a rendition of this this code a couple
of different times so we have c
a a a b um we can also apply rules over
larger swaths of text
so in this case we're taking the word
and and we're looking for it
everywhere and every time we encounter
that we might use the word and
or we might insert an ampersand instead
we can also do more complicated things
like running arbitrary javascript
um in this case we're using a regular
expression matcher that's just looking
for the first letter of words
um and it's going to then capitalize
that
and we've run this a few times over this
really lovely quote by john cage
i have nothing to say and i'm saying it
and that is poetry as i need it
and the different capitalizations that
occur kind of apply different weights
into the text and shape the sentence in
in different
ways and highlight different thoughts
and i think that's really interesting
um it can do a bunch of other things so
we have a standard library of common
functions
standard library it's actually like
three functions but they're useful
things to have around
that are then available inside the eval
api
we can call inline function calls we can
do markdown rendering
we can escape blocks and have literal
text blocks
and we can also reproducibly generate
the same text by pinning a seed
and it also works in a browser so you
can put it
in your websites um in terms of how it's
actually built
um it's just a bunch of bad javascript
and truly
evil uses of the eval command and we're
not going to talk about it
um so some of the things that i've done
with
bml um this is a
an excerpt from the source of a dynamic
poem i made and you can see the number
of chance elements and permutations
starts to become very high very quickly
but at the same time
again the larger structural ideas can
retain their shape
if that's something that you want and
you can see here's a
rendition of that poem in full um i'm
not going to
pause and dwell on it too much but you
can go back if you like and check it out
more
this was installed well
so this is a contraption i made that i
endearingly called the poetron
it's just a box with the receipt printer
and a big glowing button
and when you press the button it
generates a poem using vml and prints it
on a receipt for you to take home
i installed this in a gallery cj1
gallery in new york city
in february i think and uh i think
visitors had a lot of fun coming by and
pressing the button and printing out
versions of that that poem we were just
looking at
and taking it home with them
also because it's embeddable on websites
i've made blog posts with this
and kind of covertly just published them
as if they were well-behaved blogs
but in fact the text does change every
time you refresh the page
and really excitingly uh i'll be
publishing a full-length book of chance
poetry with austpress in 2021.
we'll be publishing one or a couple
physical versions of the book
while simultaneously publishing it
online where visitors will be able to
explore the gazillion different versions
of the poems and they'll be able to kind
of discover different versions of the
poems and share them with other people
it's going to be a lot of fun i'm super
excited about this
and just for kicks this presentation
also is
generated with bml and as i speak right
now this is the first time i've seen
this presentation i
um and i can show you the swords here um
so like one fun thing we're doing is
every time we have an exclamation mark
we repeat it some
arbitrary number of times and there's a
bunch of just like
stuff that's going on here um
so more seriously why is this
interesting
um i think dynamic text makes the
reading experience
more intimate and invites a more
critical mode of reading
maybe by reading several versions of the
same text
the reader can come closer to the
underlying thoughts of the writer
at the same time it's kind of a trope
that writing is
already a process of self-discovery but
as a writer interacting with this medium
i found a surprising and rewarding
feedback loop
between me and the text that comes out
of this
seeing my words scrambled and rearranged
and really out of my hands in some sense
has radically changed the way that i
write and think about
text and my own style
and like i mentioned at the beginning
here i think this calls into question
the idea
of the author and the assumption that
there exists a correct
text that there exists a best way to
make a thing
and at the same time that it challenges
authorship i think it challenges
ownership
a question i'd like to leave you all
with here today is
what does it mean to own a text that
nobody wrote
thank you so much uh you can find out
more about this language
at bmlang.org that's bml-lang.org
you can find me online at andrew.art and
i'd love to hear your thoughts
thank you